(uptempo acoustic music)
- Hi, I'm Hannah, your
friendly neighborhood wine mom,
and if you're anything
like me, you believe that
a glass of wine at eight
PM, every once in awhile,
don't get crazy, makes you a better mom.
So pour yourself a glass and let's talk.
By the way, did you
see we fixed the intro?
Tonight, we're drinking rose.
I bought my rose a little dress,
because one of us should
be fancy, am I right?
I just talked to my wine.
So there's something I've
been dying to tell you guys,
but first, you need a
little bit of backstory.
Both my kids go to daycare,
and they go to daycare near where I work,
so I drop them off every morning.
And every morning, I see
this cute little old lady.
I smile and I wave hello.
And every morning, she
gives me this death glare.
Just, like...
Whoa, this cute old
lady, what the heck, man.
But I realize, she's not looking at me,
she's looking at my hair.
Because I have blue hair.
This is a hot topic on all of the comments
on all these videos, too, so
I figure it's a perfect time
to talk about this.
Let's talk about the worst
things about judgy parents.
So let's start off with
what that old woman
was judging me for, colored hair.
In every video ever that I'm
in, there's some commentor
who says something like,
(in a deep voice) Ooh, she's a mom,
she shouldn't have blue hair.
My favorite color is blue,
so when I dyed my hair blue,
it just unlocked this
whole wave of confidence
and happiness, and it
benefits my kids so much more
to have a happy, confident mom.
So any moms out there with colored hair,
this one's for you.
I got a wine mustache from that one.
Next, your age.
I was pretty young when I had my first,
and I looked very young.
So I would get all these strangers,
like, at the park with their kids,
they would come up to me and
kneel down on my son's level,
and be like, where's your dad?
Where's your dad, I don't know, what?
I got shit like, oh, was he planned?
Oh, was he an accident?
Is the dad still involved?
Who's, what?
For people who are a little bit older,
they get the same thing,
like oh, aren't you tired?
Oh, don't you wish you
had done it earlier,
'cause you wanted a second?
Since when did this become your business,
weird random stranger on the sidewalk?
I feel like people thought
they could ask me all these
intrusive questions
because I did look young,
and to them, the age
that they had children
was the proper time.
So now, when I see a young mom,
I will go over and be like,
hey, you wanna come
over and have some wine?
Are you even old enough to drink wine?
Can I see your ID?
Just come on over and
let's have a glass of wine.
Next.
Something.
Next, meltdowns in public.
I have two kids, they are
four and one and a half.
They're, like, pretty
bad ages for meltdowns.
And it usually always
happens at the grocery store.
My kids always meltdown,
what do you expect?
It's like, character shit in every aisle.
So you go in one aisle,
and it's Spider-Man cereal,
you can't have that.
Go in the next aisle
and it's Captain America
fruit roll-ups, not buying that for you.
Next aisle, they're
selling Batman sugar bags.
Just bags of sugar with
Batman on the front.
And so when they do, it's like,
what do you expect me to do?
Should I just leave my cart and leave?
Like, we need groceries.
So, why are these other
parents looking at me
with a disapproving look
and, like, muttering, like,
(in a deep voice) Oh, she
should control her kids.
Usually, these parents
are parents of children
who are well past the age of mine.
Do they don't really
understand or seem to remember
what it was like?
We're not at a movie theater,
you're not paying to, like,
enjoy this experience
at the grocery store,
we're all grocery shopping.
Chill out a little bit.
In this situation, parents
should help each-other out.
If you see me at the grocery store
with both of my kids
melting, just take one.
Have it!
It's yours!
Next, milestones.
There are certain parents,
it's usually, like,
the tiger mom type, who judge your child
based on their milestones.
I got all this crap with
my oldest son because
he was two and a half and
he wasn't potty trained.
And there were all these
other moms who were like,
(in a high voice) Oh,
he's still in pull-ups?
There are some parents
who think that their child
should be potty trained
by the age of six months
or something crazy like that.
And it's because they do
this weird thing where they
hold him over the toilet
when they feel like they're
about to crap or, it's,
I don't even get it.
He's four now, and he goes
to the bathroom just fine.
It happens for each kid at their own time.
My kids' bowel movements
have nothing to do with you,
unless you would like to
come clean them up for me.
You can judge all you want,
as long as you wipe my kids' butt for me.
Next, childbirth.
There is a certain subset of moms
who are gonna judge you
for the way you gave birth.
They'll judge you if you had an epidural.
They'll judge you if you had a C-section.
They'll judge you if you had a waterbirth.
They'll judge you if you did it at home.
They'll judge you if you
did it at a hospital.
They'll judge every single
part about your birth
that's not the same as the
way that they gave birth.
Which doesn't make any sense to me,
because the kid's already out.
There's nothing we can do about it.
Like, I can't shove it
back in and do it the way
that you thought I should have.
So for both of my boys,
they were very short labors,
it was extremely painful,
and I walked right into
the hospital being like,
drugs, drugs, drugs?
I got the epidural, I
did it in the hospital,
that's where I was comfortable,
and there's always that one mom
who you tell them your birth
experience, and they're like,
(in a high voice) Oh, well I
had mine at home, with no meds.
Like they're better than you.
We both got it out!
I don't care how yours came out,
I don't care where you were.
Why do you care where mine was?
If I see a baby, I'm not like,
hmm, I wonder how it came
out of its mom's vagina.
I don't give a flying
hoot about the birth plan.
Did I just say flying hoot?
But the worst part about judgy parents,
is that we're all judgy parents.
I'm judging judgy parents right now,
y'all are gonna judge me in the comments,
you are gonna judge
each-other in the comments.
So let's just all stop.
We're all on this crap
rocket ride of parenthood,
let's be nice to each-other.
If you see something that you wanna judge,
save it for something interesting
to tell your significant other.
Hey, guess what I saw,
some dummy talking about judgy parents.
She was so dumb, she had
stupid hair, blah blah blah.
It's perfectly acceptable to be judgy,
but it's not okay to be mean.
So that's all I got for today.
I'm Hannah, your friendly
neighborhood wine mom.
It should be interesting
to see the comments
on this video, let's try to keep it nice.
'Cause I read them, I
appreciate them, and as always,
if there's anything you
want me to talk about,
leave it in the comments.
And if you have something mean to say,
take that to Twitter, because
I don't have a Twitter
and I don't know how to use it.
So, 'til next time!